the best mobile games used the medium to
deliver engaging gameplay and gripping
story and 2021 saw a number of
pocket-sized gems from lovingly crafted
rpgs to fresh spins on existing
franchises 2021 was a stellar year for
mobile gaming
here's our best mobile games of the year
for years psyonix's game about rocket
powered cars competing against each
other in a game of soccer or as i would
say football they don't say out of
bounds they say into touch
okay you owe me five bucks but i sneaked
into a sentence later has been one of
the best competitive titles that you can
play on pc or console
in a new form it's also one of the best
games you can play on your mobile device
as rocket league sideswipe takes all of
the charm of rocket league and boils it
down to a highly enjoyable and
fast-paced experience on a 2d plane it's
still as fast and as furious as ever
this time it ain't just about being fast
but with an emphasis on vertical action
and gravity-defying tactics rocket
league sideswipe is the series at its
most accessible level yet while also
offering plenty of advanced techniques
to master exquisitely designed rocket
league side swipes finely crafted action
is a template for just how the best
games on pc and console can transition
to mobile devices
2021 has been a big year for riot's
league of legends franchise and if a
recent viewing of the superb arcane
series on netflix has piqued your
interest about that universe
we will show more then wild rift is a
great place to dive headfirst into it's
essentially league of legends stripped
down to a more accessible core cutting a
substantial amount of fat from the core
product and retooling it for mobile
devices wild rift is league of legends
without any of the glut of the main game
or its intimidating learning curve an
alternative to anyone who looks at the
pc product and sees an impenetrable meta
game the expertly crafted touchscreen
controls vibrant design and easily
readable on-screen action make wild rift
one of the best mobile games of the year
on paper gentian impact sounds too good
to be true it's a collection of verdant
worlds and well-balanced gameplay and it
regularly expands with new content all
for the low low price of absolutely
nothing while there are some premium
elements to its gadget design gentian
impact straight out of the digital box
is still an incredibly enjoyable game
that offers an absurd amount of content
without having to shove
microtransactions in your face whatever
happened
to pure unadulterated great 2021 has
been a terrific year for the game with
new regions unlocked irregular influx of
new characters added to its roster and
next-gen upgrades that made an already
visually stunning game look and perform
that much better on playstation 5 and pc
mobile is no slouch either in the
graphics department but whichever
platform you grab genchin impact on the
end result is a fantasy adventure that
will have you hooked for hours on its
magical world in
genchin impact review heidi clems gave
it a seven out of ten writing gen chin
impact makes a great first impression
the anime inspired visuals are inviting
and colorful and the fully voiced nicely
choreographed cutscenes give the game
the feel of a premium product it also
gets you going with the gameplay very
quickly thanks to solid control design
you'll be running swimming climbing
dodging gliding fighting slimes and
slinging spells just a few minutes after
the intro cutscene wraps up and once
your first additional party member
officially joins your posse things start
to get very interesting as you'll start
to learn the ins and outs of the
elemental interactions that make gentian
impact unique
[Music]
fantasian is a game that knows exactly
which time-honored rpg mechanics and
ideas it wants to incorporate into its
design and with final fantasy creator
hironobu sakaguchi involved the obvious
similarities are easy to spot i am big
enough to admit that i am often inspired
by myself while fantasian doesn't stray
too far from a path that dozens of rpgs
have walked on for decades it still
manages to take those familiar elements
and polish them up to a mirror shine
adding in quality of life changes that
matter it's also a visually enchanting
game with sakaguchi having pioneered a
technique that turned dozens and dozens
of handcrafted dioramas into actual
parts of the game lending the experience
and artisanal quality that is completely
unique the biggest selling point of
fantasian though is its approachable
nature as a bounty of save points tight
controls and engaging battles help
create a game that's fantastic for
beginners and appealing to genre
veterans it's style and substance a
refined approach to a classic genre of
gaming and one of the best games you can
have on your mobile device today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pokemon's roots may lie in turn-based
rpg monster battling games it looks like
charizard is taking on that
charizard you can't just quit in the
middle of my most important match ever
but the series has never been afraid to
experiment in other genres this year's
pokemon unite may just be one of the
boldest attempts that the series has
taken to reinvigorate itself and find a
new audience as nintendo went into moba
territory with a game like league of
legends and dota 2 but with pokemon
that's a twist that's very twisty
pokemon unite still adds its own twist
to the genre formula though and as a
game that merges easy to learn mechanics
with fast and frantic gameplay it makes
a great first impression on anyone
willing to give it a try in gamespot's
pokemon unite review we scored it a 7
out of 10 with jason finnelli writing
the moba genre fits the pokemon
franchise very well and as more pokemon
are introduced the meta game will likely
continue to evolve and may introduce
more fun opportunities to strategize
dropping into battle with new builds and
trying new things is fun as is taking a
newly earned pokemon into a battle and
seeing what they can do
so there you have it gamespot's top 5
mobile games of 2021 we'll be revealing
our top 5 xbox pc switch and playstation
games as well so make sure you hit that
subscribe button so you can catch up on
all of the best games that have been
released this year and speaking of when
it comes to that coveted game of the
year trophy well we awarded it to arcane
studios death loop we have a deep dive
on the channel live right now as to why
we awarded it that prestigious prize
thanks so much for watching and remember
for all the latest when it comes to the
world of video games make sure to
subscribe to gamespot we'll see you in
2022
[Music]